hey there and welcome to propose plus
proflows plus i'm cameron and i thought
it'd be fun to do a bonus lesson for you
guys
and this bonus lesson has to do with
lights and shadows since that's what
we're talking about
i get asked a lot how
did i make the intro to the 3d camera
techniques video
if you haven't seen that video i highly
recommend you check it out it's on
youtube
a couple other social media channels
and
it's just it's a solid tutorial training
series it's the first one i ever put out
and it's got this introduction
in it where we zoom in on this
indian
i call it the indian diagram it's an old
diagram that was used in tv
and it's just got some three-dimensional
depth but it's got some interesting
lighting and shading so i thought
why not show you
how i did that or let's just try and
recreate that essentially so
here is what the final one looked like
there was some text here it said 3d
camera techniques
but essentially
the camera just starts zoomed out and
pushes in
like so so
that's we're going to do it's not going
to be exact but we'll
replicate it as much as possible
so you can see here
here is the indian shape which we see
here and i've got a floor which is just
a solid layer
and the solid
is in here and it is
going to layer solid settings
it is 1920 so it's 1920 wide it's a 1920
comp but it's
420 pixels long i don't know why it's 27
so let's just do 4 000.
so you can see
that it's a really
tall
solid layer and that's because we're
going to make it 3d
like so this is a
top angle here so let's just go to
custom view
like so
let's add a new camera
and we'll make it a one node camera and
we'll just go to 35 millimeter we'll
leave depth of field off for now
[Music]
but there it is and let's just rotate it
on
the x
negative
90 degrees and we're going to
drop that
something like this so the
oh i don't know maybe something like
this
i don't think the indian was sitting
just on top of it and
or wasn't resting on the floor was just
above it and just so you know this is a
precomp here it's an indian precomp
because it's got two layers here
there's this foreground and then there's
this background part
and the foreground's actually brought
forward in z space which you can see
here
and the reason i did that was i was
creating a little bit more depth
um
really this could be just
level here and we'd be good to go but
i'll show you why i did that so
if i turn
i have the indian here and i make it
3d as well so there's
the indian if i click this button here
collapse transformations you can see
what happened there so i collapsed
transformations but it when i did that
it's looking
inside this precomponent saying okay
well there's actually a 3d layer here
that's pushed farther forward in z space
and so it recognizes that okay so
it's like it's a pre comp that's a flat
what i call folder
but it's actually got some depth to it
now if i was to not check that box here
it is just a flat 3d layer in 3d space
so collapse transformations
has several
options to it
i guess not options several functions to
it
the most common is that when we use like
text
or we bring in a vector layer
we can click it we can turn that on for
the vector layer and then scale that
layer
exponentially up to like a thousand ten
thousand percent and that layer will
always be crisp because it continually
rasterizes it well that's one function
this is another function where it just
gives it some depth so
i'm actually going to duplicate it and
i'm going to turn off the bottom one
because in our previous example you can
see there's one on the floor here but
there's no depth to this one on the
floor and
just to reference that you can see why i
have depth of field turned on but this
this element here the foreground element
that we see right here in the front
that's why this guy is out of focus but
the rest of the indian here is in focus
so the depth of field the focal plane is
set to this part of the layer but not
this part so it just adds a little bit
more depth to it
so we have the bottom layer here let's
actually
rotate it
negative
90 as well and i just want it to sit
on that floor layer
something like that
and
i think that'll probably work
and let's go ahead and drop
this floor down a little bit more
and with that
let's also drop this guy down
and i actually i'm going to go ahead and
change my camera settings here it's a
little bit
push in just a little bit tighter there
so i can see or
a little bit wider camera so that i can
see a little bit more of what's going on
so maybe something like that this isn't
going to be exact but it's going to be
you know
close and you'll you'll get an idea for
what i did so to the floor i also had
a grid right inside of here so let's add
grid and that's under is it under
generate
grid
i found that
i changed it to width slider in the
original version i actually used a
sapphire plug-in as a sapphire grid it
had a few more options to it
i don't like how
this grid
everything's the same width right you
can't in the sapphire version you can do
like
maybe this line here is wider and these
are narrow and then wider narrow wider a
little bit more options um there's also
an interesting grid
script out there that i've got that
creates grids out of shape layers it's
pretty cool
but for this we'll do
90
and three
okay then we're gonna duplicate the
layer
we're gonna turn it
back to zero and just push it back and
space
something
so they just interact back or intersect
back here
and i'm also going to pull it up
and to do that let's go to left view
looks like that's the layer right there
i'm just nudging it with my arrow
and if you look here i pretty much had
these lines kind of lining up
like so so it kind of looks like it goes
back and then it kind of goes up
and we'll change this back to custom oh
not that one
it'll be active camera this one will be
back to custom view
something like that
yeah so let's jump back and let's take a
look yeah it looks pretty cool so i also
had another
[Music]
design
let me bring that in really quick
okay so i got this other element i
pasted in here it's just a um
if i solo this
you can see here it's just like a really
simple shape layer
it's just an l shape with a dot to it
and that's just
inside of one layer here it's just a
turn these off so we have one line we
have a second line and then we have an
ellipse here
and the ellipse is just has a trim path
set to 25
otherwise it you know can circle all the
way around or whatever
so that's all it is really simple 45
degree back i think i had a second one
that i actually brought forward up in
here
so we'll just do that really quick
and i notice with my shape layer
the
anchor point is off with the shape layer
and you've seen previous videos where i
adjust
that but for this i'm just going to
leave as is
so now i'd probably switch back into my
top view
and make sure
that these guys are kind of lining up
with the edges
that one looks pretty good like so
and let's go ahead and add
a new light
and i think i use spotlights for this
one
and we will cast
[Music]
shadows i don't want super dark shadows
though
so already some interesting
depth but i think for one of them i
actually just went behind
[Music]
and i created like this
i'm actually going to turn off snapping
here
and it's still snapping there we go
and i just wanted this light to kind of
be off to the side here
just want a little bit of light over
here so let's actually duplicate this
light
and let's bring it
now this would be a great time to do the
trick i showed you
in a previous lesson on how to control
easily control your spotlight
by adding that camera
this would be a perfect opportunity to
do it but i'm not going to do it right
now
like i said this isn't going to be
perfect
yeah and so here's where the real trick
happens so
i'm going to add another
new solid and this is going to use a
third-party
plugin which is why this is a bonus
video
and i'm going to name this solid
lux make it the same size as the
composition click ok
there we go and to this i'm going to
apply
it's a red giant
plug-in and
i actually can't remember
there's so many they've moved around so
many times
let's type in over here
lux so it's rg trap code and it's lux
so i apply it and you can immediately
see what happens up here there's like
this
looks like there's a spotlight up here
with some volume to it right
so
excuse me so what i wanted to do is i
want it to only affect this light up
here
so i'm going to say i'm going to go into
general it's a really simple plug-in
there's only a few parameters if you're
using a point light you would mess with
this i'm using spotlight so i'm messing
with this
and general is for everything so general
has three options here
i'm going to use lights that are on
the name starts with lux
so now it immediately turns off and the
look i think we'll stick with natural
we'll see
and i want this spotlight to be affected
by lux so what i'll do is i'll just hit
enter and retype
lux
now
here you can see something happening
over here you can because the lights off
screen here
so i could
control this a few different ways
you can see as i crank the intensity up
here you can see it really get intense
here it's also using the lights
intensity so if i go down here and i hit
a a
and turn up the intensity here
it does the same thing right it's just
it's a combination
of intensities essentially so
we'll go back over here to lux
start distance
i usually set this to zero
uh 10 means so if the light point is
like
zoom in here if the light is here
um
it's saying okay start your distance
farther away from the light which is
140. but if i just crank this down to
zero it's looking at where that light
starts and that's where it's going and
then the reach is this and that's where
the magic really happens with this one
you can see right here
the volume it's like there's this smoke
kind of like in the room and i extend it
a little bit further
and
let's just play around here with a
little bit with this
i can crank the intensity up and
obviously the lights here so it's more
intense here
but let's just
something like that
i think i'm going to open up the cone
angle a little bit give a little bit
more depth
something like that
now if i go back to the lux layer and i
change this from natural to like
i don't know weak there's week
linear linear to natural
then they're strong you know very
intense
adjustable linear
most the time i find myself using
natural i don't use this plug-in a whole
lot but when i do want some really
interesting volumetric light
this is my go-to there are ways of you
know building this
with the with effects that are in after
effects but i just prefer
this way and i've had this plug-in for a
long time
now something else i did is i think i'm
pretty sure i
reduced the opacity
on these indian
and you can see there what happened was
so
you can see this indian
i keep calling any but it's a diagram
see how it looks really strange down
here it's because the lux layer is below
it
so if i just take these down below lux
layer then it's part of the volumetric
feel as well
but let's just drop the opacity down
here of this guy
yeah a little bit more interesting and
then i also added
i'm actually going to save this
i also added another solid layer
just to give it a little bit more
volumetric feel
i added a gray solid
and i dropped the transparency down
like that
and i believe i scaled it up
so that's with the solid that's without
so it just adds just a little bit more
um of a layering effect to it
i also want to drop the opacity
of these guys
something like that
maybe even i'm gonna go ahead and lock
the luxe layer
i'm gonna drop this guy down just a
little bit
something like that
i know that i added a adjustment layer
i also added some noise to this puppy so
we're going to add noise
uh noise is different than grain
10
so there you can see
noises at full res
um i really liked the noise look
with the um
like the volumetric feel that's going on
so there's noise let me take a
screenshot of that
i'll turn that off and i'll add grain
here
i don't really have a rhyme or reason to
when i use noise or when i use
grain
but typically i just kind of you know i
go by my by my eye so um if i just
change this to one of the presets you
can see the grain i mean it is like
noise but it's a little bit more intense
now i can control the intensity here i
could like crank it way down
uh i mean that see i don't like that so
maybe it's 0.5
um still feels too noisy i could change
play around to different settings here
but that's why for this one i went to
just a very quick
noise
like this so i could you know turn off
color noise use black and white but i
liked the color noise
usually a low value of something like 10
maybe 12 or less is all you need
it just kind of depends on
on what you're creating
so that looks pretty cool
what else did i do i also did another
do another adjustment layer and
this will be my vignette
i don't want to do that i'm trying to
just
change the names here
vignette and
noise
and for this
i used cc vignette
and i cranked up the amount i believe
actually i don't want that much that's
too much fun yet
so maybe somewhere in here and then i'd
probably actually i don't think i did
this in the original but i'm going to
offset it
a little bit
since our light's coming from up here
maybe something like that
a lot of times i play with pen
highlights and i find myself turning
them way up so this is with without
maybe a little bit more
i don't like how harsh it is
with the um 45 degree markers here
but let's see if this gets solid let me
save this let's go ahead and turn on
depth of field and
let's set a keyframe
and let's crank up the aperture here
and might help if we turn it
on so that's pretty much it that's what
we saw we saw that this
main part was in focus this was out of
focus
so that'll work i'll set a keyframe
position
and then i started just a little bit
pushed
zoomed out here
something like that
maybe something like that now i got to
be careful of this guy
and then i did like a simple
ease in
and let's take a look at what this looks
like
so there's our preview and it's a little
more
boring i'd say than the original
um
like i said it wasn't going to be
completely recreated it's pretty close
though
one thing i noticed right off the bat
well we can't see the back grid that's a
problem
i also flew in
further so we started kind of farther
back like this
which
make sure
again i need to scale up
and we'll kind of really push this guy
in terms of speed
so we can come in quicker and then it
also i believe i had
depth of field here focus distance here
is good but when we start out here
everything was really
blurry
because i think there was like a ring i
had a ring in the front foreground
now one thing i want to watch out is the
light here so i do want to
push in
here
something like that
and we'll push in and i think i'll take
this back light here
i might have had a third light
to kind of give it some fill a little
bit
let's just check this view out we'll go
to custom view one
see where this light's going
i just want to push it back a little bit
i want to see a little bit more of that
grid
maybe increase
angle maybe to increase the intensity
that's not going to do it
so let me add one more spotlight here
and this one will just be kind of
focused over here
and make the angle pretty wide
so now we can see just a little bit more
of that grid it is out of focus
and the last thing that's bothering me
is this guy
over here
really drop the opacity down and same
with this guy back here
yeah i dig that
save in one last preview
there we go so that's pretty much how it
was done there was a little bit of text
obviously it said 3d camera and
techniques here but that's just text
in 3d space right beside this indian
shape
i think maybe i cranked the preset of
the
depth of field actually i think i left
it fast rectangle but for this i would
make it a little bit nicer i used to use
3d the fast rectangle preset for
everything i've since learned that you
can get a lot nicer results without it
but there you go there is
the intro to 3d camera techniques
hope you learned something new see ya
[Music]
you